hola a todos voy a empezar a hablar del
rotacional y el rotacional es uno de
esos conceptos increíbles del cálculo
vectorial que seguro estarás muy
contento de aprenderlo una vez que lo
hagas y si no es por otras razones
porque en realidad es artísticamente
placentero y hay dos distintas versiones
es el rotacional en dos dimensiones y el
rotacional en tres dimensiones y
naturalmente vamos a empezar a hablar de
la versión en dos dimensiones así y
después construiremos el de tres
dimensiones y en este vídeo en
particular quiero digamos simplemente
asentar la intuición de qué es lo que
está ocurriendo visualmente verdad y el
rotacional tiene que ver con el flujo de
un fluido verdad con esa interpretación
de los campos vectoriales ahora esto es
algo de lo que ya hemos hablado en otros
vídeos especialmente en aquellos en
donde hablamos de la divergencia pero
solo como recordatorio tenemos un
digamos si imaginamos que en cada punto
del espacio tenemos una partícula
digamos una molécula de aire o una
molécula de agua y dado que el campo
vectorial
asocia a cada punto en el espacio algún
tipo de vector y recuerda que no siempre
dibujamos todos los vectores sino
simplemente una
muestra pero en principio todos los
puntos en el espacio tienen un vector
atado a ellos verdad y puedes pensar en
cada partícula que de estas las
moléculas de agua o de aire que se
mueven a lo largo del tiempo en una
forma en que el vector velocidad de su
movimiento en cualquier punto en el
tiempo verdad es el vector que está
atado a ese punto verdad así que se
mueve a una locación distinta en el
espacio y el vector velocidad va
cambiando que quizás esté girando o
quizás esté acelerando y de hecho la
velocidad puede estar cambiando verdad
así que terminamos con una especie de
trayectoria para ese punto y dado que
cada punto se está moviendo de esta
forma podríamos pensar en un fluído
verdad este digamos una forma global de
visualizar el campo vectorial y para
este ejemplo particular este campo
vectorial particular que he dibujado voy
a poner una pequeña bolita azul en
distintos puntos del espacio y en cada
uno de estos podríamos pensar que
representa una molécula de agua y vamos
a darle correr a la animación así que en
cualquier momento si nos fijamos en el
movimiento de estas bolitas azules que
están
digamos siguiendo al vector que está
atado en cada punto en donde se
encuentra en verdad si ese vector no
está dibujado bueno sabemos que ahí debe
haber alguna verdad así que de esta
forma obtenemos alguna idea de qué es lo
que está ocurriendo con este flujo
completo verdad y podemos notar que hay
ciertas regiones muy particulares por
ejemplo fijémonos en esta región de aquí
a la derecha verdad
aquí podríamos concentrarnos en qué es
lo que está ocurriendo y si empezamos a
correr otra vez la animación podemos
notar algo muy particular de esta región
que hay una especie de rotación en el
sentido contrario de las manecillas del
reloj y esto corresponde a la idea de
que un campo vectorial tiene rotación al
aquí y seré más específico en lo que
significa el rotacional más adelante
pero justo ahora quiero que tengas una
idea de que en esta región donde tenemos
rotación en el sentido antihorario
verdad decimos que el rotacional es
positivo mientras que si nos fijamos en
esta región que tenemos aquí la rotación
va en dirección de las manecillas verdad
es decir en el sentido contrario y ahí
tenemos una
rotacional negativo y justo por ejemplo
por aquí verdad si nos fijamos en este
lugar en donde no hay rotación digamos
en este centro de aquí tenemos puntos
que se acercan digamos desde arriba a la
derecha y desde abajo a la izquierda y
también se alejan desde las otras
esquinas entonces en realidad no tenemos
una rotación como tal verdad simplemente
estamos jalando digamos el agua desde
este lugar y en realidad no estaría
rotando así que hay regiones en donde
podríamos pensar que tenemos rotación al
cero así que en una idea general la
rotación en el sentido contrario de las
manecillas del reloj corresponde a
rotación al positivo cuando va en el
sentido de las manecillas corresponde a
la rotación al negativo y cuando no
tenemos rotación entonces tenemos
rotación al cero y en el siguiente vídeo
empezaremos a descubrir qué significa
digamos en términos de las derivadas
parciales de la función que define a
nuestro campo vectorial digamos como
podríamos empezar a cuantificar esta
intuición que hemos desarrollado para la
rotación de un fluido y lo que es tan
genial es que no solo
de la rotación de fluidos verdad si
tenemos campos vectoriales en otros
contextos podríamos imaginar en
particular que representan un fluido
pero no necesariamente verdad la idea de
rotación de hecho tiene mucha
importancia en algunas formas que quizás
no esperarías el gradiente por ejemplo
resulta ser a esta regla relacionado con
el rotacional incluso no necesariamente
podría uno pensar que el gradiente tiene
que ver con la rotación de un fluido
verdad en el electromagnetismo esta idea
de la rotación de fluido tiene cierta
importancia incluso si aún si los
fluidos en realidad no están realmente
involucrados así que es mucho más
general que solo la representación que
tenemos aquí pero es digamos esta es una
representación visual que quizás sea
bueno tener en mente a medida que
estudiamos campos vectoriales